Bây giờ đối với phương trình bản thúc lên là ham xin.
Thấy đổi, hoàn đất, ham xin đổi, hoàn cốt.
Em học lượng ra, em biết rồi.
Chứ đi góc, bị trên 2.
Nhưng mà ở đây, bây giờ, phuyên trước nó có giống chứ.
Bài ta phải nằm mất ký giống chì vị chống đi để cho ký,
bình này nó giống.
Cậm thêm cậm, bị.
Dưới bài xả nó.
Ôi, mình gà, như nó.
Thốt quá.
Ôi, mình gà, đây.
Cậm, bị.
Chứ, phí trên 2.
Lựa cậm, bị.
Bài, cậm, đỡ vi mà chú đi bây giờ 2 và thì nên cậm bị trên 2.
Dưới bài lúc, người phương trình bản thúc, bây.
Us bài phương trình ảm.
Có dống như, phương trình gí h glo.
Tế theo phương trình rà thóc.
Chú di g Đà thóc.
Làm mất nghe tổ trường vị cho ký.
Tỉ cậm, thình có phí.
Bài thay dậm.
Này, ai, ai, ai, ai, ai.
Ông đi gắt đi đi còn vi, cột vi, thành nè, ôi gắt đi còn vi, giá đốc, nènh phá, hơi lý rộng, một góc, nè, vi.
Nhìn xưa đầu này, nữ, nữ, nữ, nữ, nữ, nữ, nữ, nữ.